[Music]  from PDA pics to a massive sparkler on  that special ring finger Khloe  Kardashian and boyfriend Tristan  Thompson seem to be getting serious so  could they be tying the knot soon a  source close to the couple tells ET  quote if things keep going the way  they're going there could be an  engagement this summer I don't know  things a little private assault mystery  is good after marrying Lamar Odom in  2009 and finalizing their divorce last  year  Khloe is in no rush vogt getting engaged  is not something she's sitting around  stressing about if it happens it happens  I'm someone who I do like to put my  relationships as a priority and I tried  to make I really try to make that work  but The Revenge body host really wants  her own kids though our source adds  quote she isn't putting pressure on  Tristan to give her that right now  the NBA star welcomed a baby boy with  his ex back in December which is a  blessing